moi
rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
commencer une série spéciale à la
découverte du littoral ouest entre
saint-paul et l'etang-salé première
étape de saint paul à boucan canot
pour partir à la découverte de la côte
ouest laventure débutons front de mer de
saint paul où nous retrouvons dédié
avril accompagnateurs en montagne
notre guide pour cette première étape
depuis le nouveau débarcadère inauguré
en 2009 on peut aisément observer le cap
la houssaye que nous aurons à franchir
pour rejoindre le camp cannot
il faut pour cela d'abord progresser sur
la plage de saint paul une belle plage
de sable noir dans lequel on retrouve de
nombreux cristaux d'olivine est surtout
connue pour être un lieu chargé
d'histoire
c'est ici que sont arrivés les premiers
colons qui ont décidé vraiment
s'installer à la réunion dans cette baie
de saint-paul qu'on appelle la baie du
meilleur ancrage derrière nous on a les
falaises justement où il ya la grotte
des premiers français
cette grotte on peut y aller pour le
moment
c'est vrai que c'est un site qui a été
aménagé auparavant qui maintenant est un
petit peu à l'abandon
on a aussi effectivement ce cimetière
alors ce cimetière marin qui a quand
même déjà plus de 200 ans
c'est vrai qu'au fil des années
d'inhumation eh bien on rencontre en
fait dans ce cimetière plein de
personnages brand plus ou moins connus
et parmi ces personnages célèbres
on a par exemple et bien le fameux la
buse l olivier levasseur qu'on appelait
la buse
et puis il ya par exemple poète leconte
de lisle pour le plus pour le plus
célèbre
voilà qui a sa tombe au milieu de
l'allée centrale au bout de la plage la
falaise de la marianne apic ne permet
pas de passer au niveau de la mer il
faut donc marcher le long de la route en
restant prudent pour atteindre
rapidement la plage de petit ans
e
pour franchir cette zone du cap
lahoussaye il faut en effet se résoudre
à marcher quelques fois sur la route
heureusement ces passages sont rares et
cours seule l'arrivée au cap la houssaye
même nécessite d'emprunter la route sur
plusieurs dizaines de mètres
le
très apprécié par les pêcheurs plongeurs
randonneurs ou simples touristes car
facilement accessible depuis la route le
cap la houssaye est un véritable trésor
géologique inscrit au conservatoire du
littoral
le piton des neiges comme le piton de la
fournaise aujourd'hui a émis des coulées
de lave la lave en gratton et puis de la
lave un peu plus compact de la lawe
cordée et c'est de l'avs en fait ces
deux types de l'avant au fil des années
se superposer et créer un millefeuille
un millefeuille géologique voilà donc
comme le gâteau on a des parties plus
tendres et des parties plus plus solide
en fait ici au cap la houssaye on voit
bien en fait ces coulées de lave en
gratton qui sont plus de couleur rouge
qui sont plus vives du coup en fer oxydé
et puis des différentes voilà d
épaisseur qui sont qui sont différentes
ce sont certaines de ces coulées nom est
rodée qui permet de continuer à marcher
au plus près de l'eau à nouveau il
faudra remonter mais cette fois-ci nul
besoin d'emprunter la route
une petite race surplombant la mer offre
de jolis points de vue
celui-ci
si tous
en suisse le
après un passage dans un bout de savane
ce promontoire au chaud permet
d'appréhender la suite du parcours
la première plage de sable blanc
corallien de l'ouest
après une descente acrobatique ou la
plus grande vigilance et de vigueur
c'est la plage du pam sucre et ses
débris de corail souvent bien conservé
mais attention à ne pas les ramasser
ils font partie intégrante du cycle de
formation de la plage
je
au bout de la plage c'est tout elle
marque l'arrivée à boucan canot et la
fin de cette première étape
cette rando allait elle est vraiment
sympathique parce que elle permet de
découvrir l'ouest vraiment différemment
dans l'habitude de passer en voiture et
en fait on passe à côté de plein de
choses en fait très sympa
et puis des paysages très variés on sent
tout le temps les embruns
en sang voilà qu'on est vraiment à côté
de cette force de la nature et
voilà on sent qu'elle est là on est
vraiment à côté de la mer alors c'est
vrai que nous les accompagnateurs en
montagne on n'a pas forcément l'habitude
de marcher comme ça au bord de l'eau et
c'est une approche qui est un peu
différente mais vraiment ces affaires
c'est une belle rando par contre sur
cette rando c'est vrai qu'on a on est
obligés parfois d'emprunter des bouts de
route
voilà on est on peut pas toujours passé
au plus près de l'eau voilà on a vu un
parfois ça passe pas on est là il ya des
caps rocheux donc on est obligé de
longer un petit peu la route alors ça
c'est parfois un petit peu moins
agréable mais ça dure jamais très
longtemps et il fait surtout il faut
être vraiment vigilant garde toujours un
oeil sur la mer parce que on peut se
faire surprendre donc ne pas s'engager
n'importe où et et regarder toujours des
cons on est très près de l'eau de voilà
deux passeurs surprendre par une vague